Karen had told me she was going to do a
video and she didn't tell me she was
going to say all of the important things
that I was going to say about Robert.
So, I'm just going to say them again
because I think they deserve repeating.
Mostly I'm kidding. Um, but before I do,
I I just wanted to say a word about this
organization and the woman who leads it.
Um, it's hard to overstate really the
importance of
the American Freedom Alliance in my
estimation. Um, those of you who are
still
surviving behind enemy lines here in
Southern California
know how vital it is
to have people who care about our
country lifted up, given platforms,
helped to amplify
the things we hold dear. And there is
simply no one better. certainly that I
can find west of the Rockies
and arguably across the country than
Karen and her team and it's pretty.
[Applause]
So, um, just a little bit more texture
on on Robert. And I'm going to consult
some notes here because it's hard when
you, as you've just seen here, when you
have so much to work with to acknowledge
it properly and and efficiently. So, I'm
going to consult these notes.
Um,
I'd consider Robert quite simply to be
one of the most brilliant,
certainly one of the most prodigiously
productive
and one of the most courageous
scholars of our time
and arguably of any time.
He has, as has been mentioned and now
exhibited, 31 books and I checked and
it's still 31,
but it it is subject to change.
And I'm fond of saying he writes faster
than I read. So I'm about 20 books back
and not closing on him. He's got,
think of it, 31 books. He started in
2022. That's more than one a year. This
is unbelievable.
And not only that, but he's got two more
that are in the hopper. They're counting
among the 31. Um, and I just want to
give a plug to them because I think, as
is true of a number of the books that
he's already produced,
they certainly deserve to be and I hope
will be bestsellers.
He's actually got two that are New York
Times bestsellers. Imagine that.
And uh and two others that are just
Garden Variety bestsellers. But in
addition, he's got coming now,
Holy Hell,
Islam's abuse of women
and the infidels who enable it. hard to
imagine a more important contribution to
the body of work in this space that he's
done. That's due out in November.
And for those of you who are planning
ahead in April of next year, he has
coming the tragedy of Islam,
failure and excuses.
Both, I hasten to add, are available for
pre-order now. So get your phones out
and get cracking.
In addition to this incredible
body of written material in book form,
uh, as has been mentioned in the video,
he's also been unbelievably
predigiously
productive in essays and articles and
commentaries.
uh to say nothing of interviews,
including I'm very pleased to say as a
regular featured contributor to my
program securing America on Real
America's Voice. He is in short one of
the go-to people and fortunately an
awful lot of important people go to
Robert Spencer as should we all.
I wanted to say that as important as is
this incredible
uh corpus on a topic very much on my
heart and I think on all of yours too,
namely
authoritative
Islam
and the Sharia doctrine that impels its
adherence
to engage in jihad.
whether the violent kind or as Robert
has described it the stealthy kind.
He's also notably through his
indispensable
jihad watch
a project of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center of which he is a Schman fellow.
Thank you Bob for that. He is also a guy
who spends time
doing something desperately needed at
the moment, which is connecting the dots
between what the Sharia adherence or
Sharia supremacists
are intent on doing to us
and their partners in crime.
That would be
the globalists
who are trying to impose upon our
country world government
and of course the communists led by the
Chinese Communist Party.
As Karen's video mentioned, we were here
back in July for a program on what I
insisted on calling not just the red
green axis between the communists on the
one hand and the Sharia supremacists on
the other, but the blue
axis for those world government, you
know, UN blue helmet types. And the
thing that Robert gets better than
anybody, I believe,
is the fact that while all of these
characters have their own
desired end states in mind,
namely
running the world according to their
lights.
They have one thing in common at the
moment
and that is getting ready getting rid of
the impediment to those ambitions
which is us.
And so I I am personally profoundly
grateful to Robert for the work he does
at Jihad Watch as well as in all of
these other respects
for doing that kind of dot connecting
for helping all of us understand who it
is we're up against what they are trying
to do to us and how they are going about
it. And I just I cannot strongly enough
encourage you to just make
jihadwatch.org or a regular
place you visit because
it's not just what he's telling you
about what's happening in our own
country, but he's really keeping his eye
on it all over the world.
And uh he's got his colleague Christine
Douglas Williams here too who does a
fair job of contributing her part to it.
I want to thank you too, Christine. But
these are really important folks doing
really important work
and it is worthy of every effort we can
make to amplify it further and that's of
course why we're here.
I don't honestly think there could be a
more important time for Robert Spencer's
voice to be heard and his body of work
to be as I say amplified.
I am proud
to call him not only
a cherished friend but a valued
colleague and mentor.
And I think there are probably not a few
of you in this room who feel the same
way.
And for more than two decades, I've had
that privilege. And so it is the
greatest of delight to be able to say on
this occasion
not only how much I rever him and am
grateful for his sacrifices, not least
that business that was alluded uh to um
by the way
you know the censorship, the
suppression, the deplatforming, the
demonetizing and all of that. But the
def efforts to kill him twice.
Once by
mass murder, gunshot,
the other by poison.
And praise be to God, he is still with
us. And that was about 20 books ago.
Imagine. I mean, think of Mozart had he
had another 20 years. We've we've been
blessed. So, I just want to say
thank you, Robert Spencer, not only on
my own behalf and that of AFA, but on
behalf of a grateful nation, for your
service to our country, past, present,
and continuing. God bless you, sir. Come
on up and get your award.
Anyway,
uh I was going to come up and say how
deeply unworthy I am of this great honor
and then I remembered uh I was reminded
this morning actually of Golden Mayer
telling someone who was getting an
award, "Don't be so humble. You're not
that great.
And so I will spare you all of that. But
in any case, I am immensely honored and
thank you. And it is actually 32 books
now. Uh a new one will be out available
for pre-order on Amazon very soon and
actually out very soon because it's a
rush called Inifat on the Hudson, the
selling of Zohan Mand Mandani.
And uh
I have been
reading and uh researching about nothing
but Zoran Mandani for the last month and
uh wrote this thing quickly. I hope that
it might prevent him from becoming mayor
or help do so. But even if he does
become mayor of New York, it seems
likely then perhaps it will serve as a
guide to why we should never do that
again. But of course he will be giving
us abundant illustration of that
himself.
In any case, uh I want to thank one
particular individual
because if it had not been for the late
great David Harowitz,
the ideas that I have tried to
spread among
well, whoever was willing to consider
them would probably never have gotten as
much of a hearing at a time when pretty
much every side of the political
spectrum had decided that
all religions are essentially good and
it doesn't really matter which one you
have as long as you have one and they
all teach magnanimity and brotherhood
and peace.
David Horowitz was willing to allow for
an alternative viewpoint as unpopular as
it was and still is of course in the
wider culture. And I think that of
course that's crucial for understanding
what we're dealing with. We have to
understand the belief system that
underlies it. And yet even to this day,
for example, if you look at the Israeli
Palestinian conflict, every last
communicate from Hamas and from Fatah
and from the Palestinian Authority and
every other group speaks all about Islam
when talking about what the conflict is
about. And not a single state department
document or UN document or EU document
ever makes any mention of Islam in
connection with the conflict.
And so if we are going to understand
that conflict properly, I would suggest
we have to respect our enemies enough to
take their word for what that why they
are doing what they are doing. And only
when we do that will we be able to deal
with the problem adequately.
Thank you. And so that writ large is the
core of all my work that beliefs matter.
They tell us this every day. We should
take them seriously and also take our
own beliefs seriously and understand
that the principles of a free society.
the principles that have made for the
greatest civilization on the planet in
the history of the world are under
severe threat and to react accordingly.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
[Music]